another big dj taking the stage in  downtown las vegas tonight  you ever heard of paul oakenfold i've  been affiliated  with vegas for a long time so i always  enjoy coming to vegas  hanging out seeing friends and the crowd  are always up for it so it's going to be  a great show tomorrow  milky dog gonna be at the downtown las  vegas event  center you may remember just a week ago  dead mouse drew 10  000 fans last friday proof of your first  vaccine or  a negative cova test they are required  to get in  it's all part of the insomniac music  group's effort to put some shows on  to make up for the electric daisy  carnival being shifted from what would  have been right now  to october